what does up or out actually mean up or
out is a principle that is applied by
McKinsey but also other consulting firms
which basically means that either you
get designated over time to the next
level or if you do not make the
promotion if you do not make the
designation then at some point you will
be asked to leave the firm so it's
either you go up or you go out and what
I can already tell you is that it is
much less cruel and horrible than what
it maybe sounds like and especially in
the lower levels of your business
analyst associate senior associate these
things are true but there's only a very
small portion of Associates who's
actually affected by that